[Music]
so
olympic gold medalist suny lee says she
got pepper sprayed during a racist
attack shut the [ __ ] up
skating and [ __ ] and then someone pepper
sprayed her she's not a like someone
nancy carried in the olympics no no no
no
in japan doing a double triple axel and
[ __ ] and like flipping around and then
someone just went
if she was doing double speed but she's
a gymnast yeah yeah she's a gymnast i
thought she was a figure skater double
triple axel they would have had to be
rotating around her during that you know
or just spraying the mist in here yeah
they're spraying it out
this is why she was here for uh dancing
with the stars right yeah she was here
for dancing yeah
she was here for dancing with stars in
l.a
uh which is why he says here
uh she was waiting for a ride after
night out with a group of girlfriends
who were all of asian descent and then
she said a car drove by the people in
and started shouting racist slurs
excuse me like that one uh no
they said uh like ching chong and
telling the girls to go back where they
came from so they told them to go back
to san jose that's hacky dude that's
hacky they said to go back to the san
gabriel that sounds like some 1980s
racist [ __ ] yeah that's what the dave
chappelle skipped remember
back to your country can't understand
you can't understand it well i didn't
know people really didn't use that one
oh yeah you know what i mean
right afterwards what pisses me off is
that every other race they get updated
racial [ __ ]
what does that mean like they call black
people a certain thing or mexicans they
update it right are you sure because
they're using slave terms from like
centuries ago all i'm saying is that
they like build the wall to like yeah
like they'll say new [ __ ] right
but then for asians they still tell us
to go work on railroads or something and
i'm like that's like 200 years ago i
don't hear no real world we still use
railroads
they're like go [ __ ] mine some coal
go mine some coal [ __ ] [ __ ] i
haven't heard that one they call this
viet congs yeah
that's at least that's newer but damn
they'll say like we're gonna go eat for
we're gonna eat dinner at petco they'll
say something like that like oh that's
updated all right that's updated that's
like more of my generation
[Laughter]
my grandpa used to call my wife charlie
but then i didn't i was like no nikki
he's like i had charlie over there oh my
god like she's filipino
her name is nikki i don't know hey
what's up with this filipino huh oh
punk ass racist
i don't know
it is i mean like okay let's it's the
classics how would you insult an asian
oh very so it's actually very easy yeah
of course it is um i say that
i um
i enjoy
your people very much
and uh i feel like you are one of me
you're you're you're just as white as i
am
[Laughter]
you're just as wide as i can that's
called the inertia up and you just like
[ __ ] flip it see that's an update on
that see that's updated it's very much
intellectual disc yeah i wouldn't even
know how to respond to that and i know
that one hurts a particular way because
of harvard and all these places that are
like kicking out asians making sure that
they don't treat them like minorities
it's like we get treated like white
people without the privileges
that's kind of true
that's not fair say that to them minor
minorities i don't know how does that
work
you looking at me so so we were out
clubbing and then they were like ching
chong ling long and then they [ __ ]
sprayed them in the face
[Music]
well they were driving and i don't know
if you if you've been around pepper
spray when it goes off yeah it's [ __ ]
it's sucks bro it's soft [ __ ] around at
parties and do that [ __ ] in the backyard
everyone had to leave yeah i was choking
on a show and there was like a huge
brawl that broke out and they came and
like they pepper sprayed it but we were
still inside the small building and all
of it just got in like i couldn't
breathe i thought i was going to pass
out
yeah it was it's hard dude i've been
pepper sprayed pretty hard so yeah she
says she was mad she was very mad
because there was nothing she could do
she pulled out a gun yeah she could have
pulled a gun but she i would recommend
it though let's get the video game maybe
would have messed with the wheaties
advertisement but who knows she says she
didn't do anything
to them and just having a reputation
it's hard because i didn't want to do
anything that could get me into trouble
right because you you have all kinds of
[ __ ] brand stuff that's what you're
doing if you're in that position your
whole life is brand right perfect i
thought it would have helped her brand
she's like a woman fights back like if
she would have [ __ ] superwoman that
[ __ ] pull the guy out of the car beat
his ass up i think everybody would have
been like yay let's put her on the
[ __ ] cracker jack cereals i mean uh
the
cracker jacket rejects here
how come we don't have anything updated
from crackers yet yeah that's true
you're right the box is still still the
same old box the [ __ ] and they still
give out shitty choices like crackers we
don't want to be you know yeah i'm fine
with cracker i don't like i like
crackers crackers are delicious
are delicious crackers okay to say it
you know what they gotta change the name
of is cheese nips i don't stand for that
[ __ ] they're not around anymore are they
yeah i see it at the store every time i
see it my heart breaks man what's cheese
i thought it was cheese why can't you
say cheese nips because nips is uh
yeah narration for japanese oh is it
really
because i used to be like oh my nips are
getting cold and then they're like did
you know
that was a word used to discriminate us
and i was like really that's what it
means nips
what about just nips like nipples like
there's awesome chaps and nips oh yeah
that's kind of like flips for filipino
yeah but we don't give a [ __ ] about that
you know that sounds like that sounds
cool it's like a little sounding wand
it's like an abbreviation
yeah yeah yeah yeah or something like
like nah i'm not trying to be racist but
like japs i'm like that's okay i guess
that's an abbreviation that's what i
thought too and you know people in
australia they say jab like that's like
a slang or whatever but they didn't know
that in america you can't say that [ __ ]
aussies it's different right i feel like
abbreviations
are
potentially useful if people don't get
too offended by them
i think it's the it's the context of how
it was used sure kind of like um
like you can't say colored people right
like you can't say that because it's
like the the era that it was tied to
yeah i understand yeah what do you say
but you can say people of color yeah or
some [ __ ] like that i don't know
transitively the same but i don't get it
because i was in a sick i think it's a
60s thing different from era for me but
like i think it's all those things like
it's tied to that map this is kind of
weird too it's like we used to say flip
all the time in high school like to
abbreviate ourselves and then somebody
said hey you know you guys people used
to say that against filipinos at a time
where it was derogatory and then
being aware of that now there's a
sensitivity but it's like if no one ever
told us yeah a [ __ ] would have the
information that would have just died
out and there would have never been a
racist connotation well because you're
like in in the 2000s it's like we didn't
know so it's almost like should you just
keep that [ __ ] history alive so that
people can continue to be offended or
just [ __ ] forget about it yeah that's
that's the debate i've never heard
well
exactly i don't know if i could say it
hey what was it i think unfortunately
everything's sanctioned in this room
everything
flip came from his first recorded 1585
to 95 it appears to be related to
it may even be a contraction of the word
philip like filipino right 1585 they've
been talking [ __ ] i get them dude
they've been talking [ __ ]
bro 1585
the ultimate way to insult these people
500 years this is gonna stick no so it
says this word means to strike with the
nail the fingers snapped from the end of
the thumb
what
compared to flip like flip a coin yeah
like that oh like flip yeah like snapped
yeah like flip
that that's the meaning literally
yeah that's that's what i thought it was
like oh you know you know what i heard
um like where this kind of [ __ ] still
happens how dare you
so um the midwest north carolina
north carolina yeah i have a hmong buddy
out in north carolina he was telling me
that you know this still happens where
guys would roll by and they'll be like
[ __ ] chinese or whatever and then
he's like i'm mong
that's like you're immune
like very rare it happens in l.a yeah
i'm sure but it just happened maybe
because i know what we're talking about
maybe because i live in a place that has
80 chinese the only person that's doing
it to me is cambodian or something
okay real quick i do i can't i can't uh
not say that it actually means for it
means [ __ ] little island people i
guess
whoa
that's what it is it was the origin of
the word flip f-l-i-p yeah there's like
funny funny little island person or it's
like a but then it almost that's
after the fact
that's the thing it's like like choosing
an acronym after it's already convenient
this is the way this is the way i saw it
people be like no that's [ __ ] like if
you just
stopped with the flow of information of
what the racist term was for filipinos
then when someone's pissed at me they
would just not know what to say but if
we keep [ __ ] giving them hey in case
you don't like this filipino guy call
him a flip it's like we just [ __ ]
stopped passing that info down for 500
[ __ ] years save this one i do think
though with like they just hate me as a
person yeah yeah
with uh not like you know with
population like you see less of it
because it's like if if there's more of
asians and [ __ ] like you're not gonna
have an opportunity to have a racist
encounter because like this guy um
he's from boston he's like a he's like a
politician now here in california like a
senator or whatever but he was talking
about growing up in boston
it was normal for like people to call
him [ __ ] or whatever off the street and
then but in california he says you don't
really deal with overt racism in that
way like growing like when you move to
san francisco no one's gonna walk up to
him and call him straight up like
[ __ ] [ __ ] or whatever so that's
prevalent no like we got like you know
growing up here i'm not saying that it
doesn't happen right what i'm saying is
the prevalence and openness and the
overtness versus versus maybe it happens
like like bran i ran into neil nazis in
huntington beach it happens right for
sure but like the frequency and how like
everyone like oh yeah that [ __ ] happened
to me and [ __ ] boston right the
commonness how common it is completely
different so me like you know growing up
in la and whatever like
to me i'm like oh that's a thing of the
past but not really if you grew up in
maybe [ __ ] north carolina just lower
probability out here yeah like no one
yells at the door like [ __ ]
ching chong ling long ting long right no
one does that [ __ ] to me
they'll just be like hey fool let me get
a picture with you yeah but i feel like
that [ __ ] does happen it does happen for
girls
more often than guys for sure yeah
that's true guys just [ __ ] with girls
generally
like out in the street so if it's like a
gang of asian girls that is what a
[ __ ] idiot that's some cowardly [ __ ]
like pepper spray a bunch of girls but
that's what people do right they target
people that they know that they could
[ __ ] with like they'd be punching the
asian grandmas i would have never even
thought to beat up a grandma dude that's
crazy i was a i was in texas a couple
months ago for a bachelor party a bunch
of [ __ ] asian dudes and uh literally
we just went to a lake in texas and then
when we finished with the lake a white
truck drives by with a bunch of white
dudes in it and they chucked their empty
like bottles of like gators and stuff at
us the chinks and then just drove off i
was like oh wow
i was like that was very bold in the car
and i was like
that was a good attack you're like
texas yeah joe bi can't see you anymore
like wonderful job execution damn
99 of the times they're just [ __ ]
yeah why is it always like that like let
me just drive cucks dude like
at least the neo-nazis had like the
decency to let us rumble yeah yeah
saving your face huh
the neon nazis had a lot of decency
jojo's a coward
they're the better version you're not
the apologist i hate it when you can't
fight back like they just run away it's
like just come on man like [ __ ] i don't
care if you jump me let me get a few
hits in dude [ __ ] let me get a few hits
in there like jojo chica said you can
say a lot of things about neo-nazis but
they were not cowards yeah they do have
a lot of honor
goddammit
you